Do please take your Bibles and turn with me to John chapter 8.
We're going to be reading a few verses from there and a bit later on we'll look at John
chapter 20.
It's also in your worship guides if you want to look there.
Just as you're turning, let me just say over the next few weeks as we're leading
up to Easter, like many other churches, we will be focusing our attention on Jesus.
We're going to do so particularly by looking at the I am statements of Jesus in the
Gospel of John.
There are seven of them and each of them are connected to a picture.
You have Jesus in John 6 saying I am the bread of life.
You have him in John 8 saying I am the light of the world.
And then chapter 10, I am the good shepherd.
I am the door.
In chapter 11 he says I am the resurrection and the life.
Chapter 14, I am the way, the truth and the life.
And then finally in chapter 15, I am the true vine.
But then there are other times when he simply says I am.
So when you're looking at all of that happening in John, you see that the thing that all of
those statements have in common are those two words, I am.
And then there are other times in the book where there's no picture connected to it,
but Jesus says I am.
So what is he talking about?
Well, let's read John chapter 8 beginning in verse 31 together.
So Jesus said to the Jews who had believed him, if you abide in my word, you are truly
my disciples and you will know the truth and the truth will set you free.
They answered him, we are offspring of Abraham and have never been enslaved to anyone.
How is it that you say you will become free?
Jesus answered them.
Truly truly I say to you, everyone who practices sin is a slave to sin.
A slave does not remain in the house forever.
The son remains forever.
So if the son sets you free, you will be free indeed.
Then go to verse 51.
Truly truly I say to you, if anyone keeps my word, he will never see death.
The Jews said to him, now we know that you have a demon.
Abraham died as did the prophets.
Prophets, yet you say, if anyone keeps my word, he will never taste death.
Are you greater than our father Abraham, who died and the prophets died?
Who do you make yourself out to be?
Jesus answered, if I glorify myself, my glory is nothing.
It is my father who glorifies me of whom you say he is our God.
But you have not known him.
I know him.
If I were to say that I do not know him, I would be a liar like you, but I do know
him and I keep his word.
Your father Abraham rejoiced that he would see my day.
He saw it and was glad.
So the Jews said to him, you are not yet 50 years old and have you seen Abraham?
Jesus said to them, truly, truly, I say to you, before Abraham was, I am.
So they picked up stones to throw at him.
But Jesus hit himself and went out of the temple.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, as we've just heard from the very words of Jesus, that your word is truth.
And your truth sets us free.
Lord, I pray that you would speak to us now through the truth of your word.
Lord, I pray that we would receive it by faith and that we would know the life
and the freedom that is found in Jesus.
We ask all of this in his name.
Amen.
All right, so we're looking together now at the gospel of John.
And it might be helpful for just to start off by saying, well, what is a gospel?
That we talk about that from time to time.
What what are the gospels?
Well, the gospels are these biographical accounts of Jesus.
And John is one of four biographical accounts that are in the New Testament.
You can look at other letters that are written as kind of eyewitness testimony,
but you have these in particular that are kind of put for us as biographies.
And so what is writing here about Jesus isn't putting him before us as mere legend,
but as history.
And what is being written is being written as an eyewitness account.
And it's being written within the lifetime of the eyewitnesses.
And John is putting himself forward as one of these eyewitnesses of Jesus.
And so we might naturally wonder, well, how can we know that this is an eyewitness account?
How can we know that it's genuine?
Well, could I just make a book recommendation before we move on?
I'm just going to briefly touch on this, but look at Can I Trust the Gospels
by New Testament scholar Peter Williams?
But there are several different lines of evidence in that book that he looks at.
But one of the things that he draws your attention to in the book
is how the Gospels are just dripping with all kinds of details.
And the level of seemingly insignificant details,
he kind of makes the case that they actually attest to the fact
that they were written by people who were extremely familiar with the context
they were writing about.
One of the things I find interesting that he talks about
are the are the different names that are scattered throughout the Gospels.
You read about the names of specific places, right?
So the Gospel writers are writing about the names of towns and regions
and bodies of water and botany.
And all of it lines up with what we know about that particular place,
at that particular time.
Now, that cannot be said for other Gospels that were written much later on.
Like you can look at other other Gospels, the Gospel of Thomas or Barnabas
or whatever that were written who do not have that level of specificity
when it comes to these names and places.
And so it's showing that they were not written within that kind of eyewitness
timeframe or rather kind of forgeries later on.
You also get the names of people.
And so these names of people, they line up with the names of people at the time,
of course, but also these names of people are there
because they could also attest to the fact that these were eyewitness accounts.
So there's some people that are named and other people that are not named.
And generally speaking, it's believed that the people that are named are named
because as these letters are first being circulated, as these biographical accounts
are being circulated, these people are still living and they can talk about
what they have seen.
You can go and speak to any number of them.
But the most extraordinary claim in the Gospel is another name.
It's the name that Jesus ascribes to himself.
And by the way, if the Gospels were just making ordinary claims,
they would be taken as history.
You can read about the Emperor Tiberius and his four accounts of his life
and so much other history at the time.
So they would be taking as history.
But the reason why there is doubt cast upon them is not because they can't be
backed up historically, but rather because of the extraordinary claims
that they make, particularly about who Jesus is and what he did.
And all of that's kind of summed up in this name that Jesus ascribes to himself.
Well, we've just read this account in John chapter eight, where Jesus is speaking
to a group of Jews and he's teaching them that he came to bring the truth
and the truth that he brings would set people free.
They are offended by this.
And so what do you mean set free?
We're not enslaved to anything or any body, but the reality is
they like everyone are enslaved to sin and to death.
And that's what he has come to set us free from.
But they thought they were OK because they were children of Abraham.
They thought they were OK because of their ethnicity, in other words.
So they were thinking, well, who does this guy think he is?
And then Jesus makes that stunning claim in verse 58.
Truly, truly, I say to you before Abraham was I am.
Essentially, he doesn't say before Abraham was I was like that would be
quite an extraordinary claim to say he was somehow made an appearance back then.
But he's claiming something far greater than that.
And you can see that the people are so enraged that they're picking up
these stones to stone him because of this claim, because they knew what he was
claiming by ascribing this name, I am to himself.
So what we're going to do for the next few moments.
And then as we really look through the the Gospel of John as a whole
for the next few weeks, we're going to be asking these questions.
First of all, who is Jesus?
What is this name all about?
Also, what did Jesus do?
And lastly, how we should respond to him.
OK, so what does John tell us about this this name?
Who is Jesus?
What is this name that he ascribes to himself?
Well, let's turn together to John chapter 20.
John chapter 20, we're going to look at verses 30 and 31.
So while John is writing history, he's not intending this to be like
like a photograph where you've got every just kind of detail there in the moment.
It's more like a painting that he is painting.
So what he is saying is factual, but yet he is not just presenting the facts.
He is preaching a sermon, so to speak.
He's he's he's he's he's crafting what he is writing.
And he's right up front about this.
So let's read John 20 verses 30 and 31 says, Now, Jesus did many other
signs in the presence of the disciples, which are not written in this book.
But these are written so that you may believe that Jesus is the Christ,
the Son of God, and that by believing you may have life in his name.
So he writes about what Jesus did, but he's not merely writing about
something about someone who was.
He says, I'm writing so that you might know who Jesus is, that he is the Christ.
So he's writing that we might know the Jesus that he came to know.
And he tells us that we too can have life by believing in his name.
OK, so his name is mentioned here.
So what is this name?
Well, when scripture speaks about names, it's speaking about more than
just just a label that somebody has on himself.
Well, I think you can get this in other cultures.
I know I haven't talked to him for a long time, but he was from Ghana.
And his name is Kofi.
And his name is Kofi because he was born on a Friday.
Right. So there's a lot of people in cultures there where their name is
attached to the day of the week they were born.
So their name tells you something about themselves.
And there are certain like Native American cultures where people's
names can change over time to connect more with their personality
or their or their accomplishments or major events in their life.
So their name reveals something about them.
And that's what's going on in scripture.
When God's name is given, he is revealing something about who he is.
It's a revelation of his nature.
So you get this next chapter three.
You get this account of God making himself known to Moses in the burning bush,
this bush that is burning, but not consumed.
And at the burning bush, God speaks to Moses and he tells him about how he's going
to deliver his people from slavery and how he's going to bring them into
the land that he had promised them.
And then Moses then asks this important question next to this three, 13 and 14.
He says, if I come to the people of Israel and say to them,
the God of your fathers has sent me to you and they ask me, what is his name?
What shall I say to them?
God said to me, yes, God said to Moses, I am who I am.
Say this to the people of Israel.
I am has sent me to you.
So Moses, this is my name.
I am who I am.
So his name is revealing that God absolutely is.
So what is this name telling us about God?
What does he mean when he says I am?
Well, there's a whole lot that we could list out.
So just take a couple.
One of the things he's telling us about himself is that he is eternal.
Unlike us, he doesn't have a beginning.
He doesn't have an ending.
He simply is.
He's eternal from everlasting to everlasting.
He is God.
But also he's telling us that he is self-existent.
OK, so the bush there is an image that's there for us.
So he is the bush is burning, but is not consumed as he announces
that he is who he is.
So like unlike any other fire,
this fire does not need fuel.
So when God is speaking through this burning bush and he's saying I am,
he's also saying that his existence is not contingent upon anything outside of himself.
Instead, all reality is contingent upon him.
Right before anything was he didn't need anything to exist.
And he then brings everything into being and he's in no way dependent upon his creation.
He simply is.
So he's the creator, the sustainer, and he's well able to be the savior of his people.
And this name, the I am, which means to be, goes on.
I, yeah, it goes on to be the kind of root of the name that is God's name most used for
or in the Old Testament.
So his name is Yahweh right throughout the Old Testament or Lord.
And at the root of that is to be this Yah Yahweh, I am who I am.
Now back to the Gospel of John.
This is the very name that Jesus is taking upon himself.
You can see why people reacted with such hostility towards him.
They know that he's claiming to be the I am who I am.
How could this possibly be?
He's claiming to be God himself manifest in the flesh.
You see this not just in that statement and the I am statements.
You see this throughout the Gospel of John.
Right in the beginning, you see that Jesus has put before us as the creator
who's bringing about a new Genesis, right?
So John chapter one and verse one, how does it start?
In the beginning, right?
Well, what does that cause us to harken back to, right?
Genesis chapter one and verse one in the beginning God created.
But here it says in the beginning was the word and the word was with God
and the word was God.
So you have this divine word that is both as divine.
So it is God and yet it is distinct from the father.
OK, so it's saying that Jesus is God and yet he is distinct from his father.
And this word in verse 14, it tells us in John chapter one was made
flesh and dwelt among us and we beheld his glory, the glory as of the only
begotten of the father full of grace and truth.
And so God is present among us.
And what does he come about to do?
What does the creator among us to do?
Well, he comes about to bring a new creation.
She's seen John chapter one and verse 12 that he gives new life,
new birth to those who believe in his name.
So this is the new Genesis that he is bringing about.
So the I am is among us and he is bringing about this new creation in the new life
that he is giving to those who believe in his name.
But also he's bringing about a new exodus, right?
The I am who spoke to Moses is bringing about this new exodus.
He's the one who's come to deliver us from sin and death and to bring
us into his eternal kingdom.
So you see that in what John says about Jesus there in chapter one,
but then you also see that continuing in what Jesus says about himself
throughout the gospel, especially in the I am statements.
And so you can understand their reaction when they pick up stones to throw at him,
or you can understand the reaction of worshiping him, putting your faith in him.
But the reaction that makes perhaps the least sense is probably the most
common reaction in Western culture at the moment is where we maybe think of Jesus
as as inspiring or as a as a as a great teacher.
You can only think that if you don't actually get to grips with what he
actually taught about himself, this guy actually either actually is the I am
himself manifested in the flesh, or he is insane or or or evil.
Either he's crazy or he is the I am, but he merely can't be just a good teacher.
So we see that through what Jesus says, but also we see it in what Jesus does.
All right, so we see who Jesus is in the gospel.
John, we're also seeing what Jesus does.
I don't know if you've seen the memes kind of floating around the Internet
about like if I ever won the lottery, I wouldn't tell anybody, but there will be
signs. I don't know if you've seen that and could be like somebody's got a
full size Millennium Falcon in their backyard or a house full of golden
retrievers or a carton full of dozens of eggs, things like that.
So if I win the lottery, I won't tell you, but there will be signs.
Right. So Jesus here doesn't just tell us that he is the I am.
He shows us and the word that John uses to talk about him showing us that he is
the I am is the word signs.
Right. So Jesus is the I am and there will be signs.
So you see that in chapter 20, verse 30, we read it a moment ago.
Now, Jesus did many other signs in the presence of his disciples, which
are not written in this book.
Now, that's not the first time signs were written about.
That's kind of like at the end for him kind of summarizing.
So he's saying there's much more that he could have written about, but he is not
once again aiming to give a comprehensive account.
He's telling us what we need to know to see Jesus for who he truly is.
And he's doing so in this kind of masterful way, even using rich symbolism as well.
So how do we know that Jesus is God with us?
How can we know that he is the creator and redeemer and able to give new life?
There's signs.
So chapters two to eleven in the Gospel of John is often referred to as the book of signs.
Most of the signs that are in John are there.
So in chapter one, we saw that Jesus is the is spoken of as the agents, both of
the creation and the new creation, but it doesn't stop there.
There there's further echoes of creation in that chapter, which we won't get into.
But then they it continues on that theme in chapters two to eleven.
And in chapters two to eleven, instead of seeing the like seven days of creation,
we see seven miraculous signs, which are almost certainly a kind of an echo of
what we see in the days of creation in the seven signs showing that Jesus is the
I am. We see the sign of Jesus turning water into wine, healing the officials
sign, healing the lame man, walking on water, feeding the multitude,
healing the blind man, raising Lazarus.
So these signs are there in order to signify something, right?
Their sign posts, if you will, pointing to who Jesus is.
So when he performs the first sign, turning water into wine, it says it clearly
that it was there as a sign to manifest his glory.
They're there to point to the reality of who Jesus really is.
He is demonstrating that he is the I am.
He can not only give like temporary life, but new life that lasts forever,
eternal life.
Now you can push this too far in choosing like, like looking at like seven
signs here and like really kind of pushing into the details, trying to make all the
connections. But this is almost certain that John is saying,
look here through these through these seven signs.
Look, Jesus is the Creator himself among us.
He is the one who can give you eternal life.
Of course, like I said a moment ago, you also have these throwbacks to the exodus.
You have this even in the signs as well.
So how how would how would the people of God know that the I am was dwelling
among them and come to deliver them and was going to lead them into the
Promised Land? Well,
what was the word that was spoken, but also the signs that were there and
the plagues that were in Egypt and signs in the wilderness as well.
They're showing God's presence and his power to save.
Regardless of the number of them or how specific the parallels are in John,
they are absolutely pointing to Jesus as Creator and Redeemer.
Now, that's the first half of the book, these seven signs.
But what about the second half of the book of John as we walk through that
together? Well, in the second half of the book of John, you have put before us
basically one major sign that's put before us as the as the greatest sign
that stands in the category all of its own.
If the first half of the book of John is the book of signs,
the second half is the exaltation of Jesus, his exaltation.
That's chapter 12 to the chapter 20.
And then there's a kind of final chapter in chapter 21.
So the first half covers a longer period of time in Jesus' ministry.
But when you get to the second half, it's focusing on a very specific time
and it is centering around Jesus' death and then his resurrection.
And it is put before us as Jesus' glorification or his exaltation, if you will.
You see this when Jesus says in chapter 12 and verse 23,
the hour has come for the Son of Man to be glorified.
How is he going to be glorified by being crucified?
Anything goes on to speak about his death.
He is going to be lifted up exaltation language that John uses here,
but he's going to be lifted up on a cross.
How can crucifixion be glorification?
Doesn't doesn't seem like that.
That could be the case.
So what is happening on the cross that is Jesus being glorified there?
Like maybe we can understand it in relation to the resurrection or his ascension.
But how can the cross be glory?
Well, on the cross, the I am is manifesting his glorious love for us.
That's where the glory of his love is seen.
So as we see Jesus lifted up on the cross, taking our sin and death upon himself,
we are witnessing the God who not only created us,
but loves us enough to do that for us to die in our place.
As we're looking to Jesus at the cross, we're seeing that the I am
loves us with an everlasting love like the everlasting one.
Loves us with an everlasting love and that's shown to us in Jesus.
The God who is self existent, not contingent upon anything else,
loves us not because there is something lovely in us,
not because he is drawn to us because of how impressive we are or how good we are or whatever.
He loves us because he loves us.
He chooses to set his love upon us.
His eternal love.
So as he did in creation on the sixth day of the week then,
Jesus having accomplished the work that he came to do said,
it is finished.
Then on the seventh day, his body was there resting in the tomb,
God who rested.
And then on the first day of the week, he rose again,
bringing about the dawn of the new creation.
So the eyewitnesses saw him, right?
They saw the signs.
They saw his death.
They saw him resurrected.
We might say, well, what are we given?
Right?
They had these signs in front of them.
What what signs are we given?
Well, they are recorded for us in scripture.
So John writes in chapter 20 and verse 31,
that these are written so that you may believe.
Well, somebody might say, well,
I guess maybe if I saw the signs that they saw like if I was like there
and saw the miracles and whatever,
maybe I would I would be able to believe them.
Well, the answer is not necessarily.
There were plenty of people who saw Jesus then who rejected him outright.
He would not believe in him who would not follow him.
He would still choose to go their own way.
So the question is, how are we going to respond?
To his word, what he says.
What God speaks to us about in scripture.
The fact is the God who spoke the universe into existence.
The God who has spoken to us in his living word, the Son.
Speaks to us in his written word.
And just as he spoke creation into existence.
So he gives new life through his word.
That's how God has always brought about creation.
So how are people made new in Jesus through the word of the gospel by
believing what he has put before us in scripture?
And that God who was present among us in the person of Jesus is
present in the person of his spirit.
And what is his spirit doing?
What he opens our eyes that we might see the Jesus revealed in scripture
and be brought into a living relationship.
With this one who loves us.
Now we can't give ourselves this new life, but that doesn't mean
that we sit around kind of waiting for it to happen either.
Right.
So God has spoken.
Jesus has told us like this is who I am.
And he's shown us who he is by dying for us on the cross, particularly.
But how do we experience the new life that is found in Jesus and Jesus alone?
What comes through how we respond to the message of Jesus about who he is?
One of my favorite movies of all time and certainly my most favorite
alien movie is the movie signs.
Have you seen the movie signs?
Just a great one.
M. Night Shyamalan highly recommended.
Mel Gibson plays the the role of a lapsed Episcopal priest.
And he's left the ministry after the death of his wife.
And there's a there's a there's a scene.
There's so many great scenes in it, but there's a particular scene at night
when he and his brother are just sitting on the couch and they are glued to the TV.
And they're watching.
Yeah, it started out with all these crop circles that the aliens were coming.
And then all of a sudden now there's these lights in the sky like these UFOs are now above us.
And it's appearing all over the world and they're sitting just glued to the television watching this.
And and they're getting kind of more frightened as they're watching what is going on.
And then the brother in particular is just freaking out.
And so he asks Mel Gibson's character Graham for some comfort.
He's like, come on, like, I know you're not doing the priest thing anymore,
but give me some comfort for old times sake.
And Mel Gibson's character says, well, there are two kinds of people in the world.
Number one, there are those people who see signs, people who feel that deep down,
no matter what happens, there will be someone to help them.
And that fills them with hope.
They said, but there's another kind of people and those are the people who just see things as pure luck or coincidence.
And deep down, they feel that whatever happens, they will be alone.
And that fills them with fear.
Here's what he then said, see.
You have to ask yourself what kind of person are you?
Are you the kind that sees signs, sees miracles?
Or do you believe that people just get lucky?
The poignant question is the kind of question, the point of the movie signs, which kind of person are you?
When you hear about Jesus, when you see what scripture reveals about him,
what sort of person are you as you look at your life?
What sort of person are you?
Are you the person who rejects Jesus and chooses to go through life then on your own?
Or are you the person who then receives Jesus, who believes in him and knows life with him?
John makes it clear to us that it is those who believe in him who are given life in his name.
So we're called here clearly to believe.
So John is writing, John 2031, this is written so that you may believe that Jesus is the Christ.
It's clear.
Like I'm writing this because I want you to believe.
You need to believe.
In fact, he uses that word 98 times in this gospel.
So this is not hidden in any way.
So it's really important.
So what does it mean to believe in Jesus?
What's more than just intellectual ascent?
Like do you believe this fact?
Do you believe this fact?
Repeat after me.
You know, it is a complete trust in Jesus.
It's in trusting ourselves to him.
So we're not trusting in our good works.
We're not trusting in our, like of course we're called to think these things through.
It's put before us here so that we can do that.
But we're not trusting in our intellect or our emotions, how we feel about things.
We're called to put our trust in Jesus.
So what are you putting your trust in?
Hear these words from Jesus.
Probably the most famous words in the Bible.
Found in John chapter 3 and verse 16 that God so loved the world that he gave his only son.
Whoever believes in him, whoever believes in him should not perish but have everlasting life.
So you believe, you live.
And this life that Jesus gives stretches out into eternity, but it's not just about where you go when you die.
Maybe we've thought about the gospel in that way.
It's just about what happens after death.
That's not the case.
Eternal life begins now.
It's about being born of God and living the life that you were made for it now.
And that is the life that only Jesus can give.
And that life with him goes on forever.
And it is the I am, the one who eternally is.
Who is the source of that life.
So the gospel here ends with this call to believe him.
But then in chapter 21, there's a call to his disciples to then follow him.
Where is the life of God, this eternal life seen in our lives.
It's seen as we follow Jesus and learn to be his disciples.
So this is for all of us.
So the call here is to put your faith in the Jesus and by his help live the life that you have been made for as his follower.
And that life is rooted in his name.
One of the wonderful things we see in John is that it doesn't just tell us about Jesus' name.
We have Jesus also calling other people by their name as well.
And he still does that today.
He calls specific people to put their trust in him and to follow him.
I pray that we would all hear him calling us and that we would come.
Let's pray that we might do that.
Thank you for making yourself known to us in Jesus.
Or thank you for making yourself known to us through your word.
And Lord I pray that by your spirit we would each hear not only this name of who you are,
but Lord I pray that we would hear you calling us by name.
And Lord we would put our faith in you.
And Lord I pray that you would help us to follow you and know your life at work in us.
Lord I pray that all of this would lead us to worship you, that we would give you the glory that is due to your name.
We pray all of this in your wonderful name. Amen.